للحصول على بعض الراحة والراحة في الوقت الحالي
، أنتجت جوقة NHS البريطانية للتنفس الانسجام
نسخة غلاف من أغنية ماريا
كاري الناجحة في أي وقت تحتاج فيه إلى
صديق من الولايات المتحدة إلى
أستراليا اجتمع أكثر من مائة مغني
من جميع أنحاء العالم
لإرسال رسالة  التضامن مع الجميع
في الخطوط الأمامية لمحاربة هذا
الوباء ، استمع إلى
[موسيقى]
لم
نكن نتذكر
أبدًا إبقاء
الرواية مزينة
[الموسيقى]
في
[الموسيقى] في
بعض الأحيان تحتاج فقط إلى فاصل موسيقي
والانضمام إلي الآن بالنسبة
لنوال دونوفان.
أخصائي العلاج الطبيعي العصبي يعمل
في كل من شارع.  Thomas and guys Hospital الذين
غنوا السطر الأول في الفيديو الذي
رأيناه للتو وانضم إلينا أيضًا
المخرج الموسيقي وراء هذا المشروع
Mike King مرحبًا بكما ،
دعني أسألك أولاً
Finola ، لديك صوت رائع و
كنت تغني كما قلنا ذلك
السطر الأول وطوال ما كان عليه الأمر بالنسبة
لك للتخلي عن دورك الطبي الذي تعرفه
وتولي هذا
الأداء العلني الآن ، مرحبًا ، شكرًا لك ، لقد
كان الأمر صادقًا عندما حاولت النظر إلى
إنها الطريقة التي يمكننا بها محاولة مساعدة الناس
أكثر لأننا نقدر أنك
ربما تكون خائفًا جدًا وقلقًا بعض الشيء
ووحيدًا في المنزل ، لذلك لم أكن
أفكر كثيرًا من وجهة النظر هذه ولكنني
أفكر أكثر في كيف يمكن أن يساعد هذا
الآخرين ونحن  لقد حصلنا على فريق دعم رائع ،
لذلك كان الأمر ممتعًا أيضًا ، ربما
سألت مايك كينج لأنك
ساحر الإنتاج الموسيقي الذي جمع كل
ذلك معًا ، أعني أنك
تعلم أنك تعتقد أنه  فجأة
كل هؤلاء الناس فجأة  هل تعلم أنه يمكنك
الحصول على التكنولوجيا والحصول على الأغاني والحصول
على الموسيقيين على الآلات والقيام بذلك
ولكن من الواضح أنهم لا يحتاجون إلى ميكروفون King
ما هو هذا النوع من الإنتاج
ونوعية ما تسمعه أعتقد أنه
رائع والحيوية هي أن هذا
تم تسجيل هذه الأغنية على الهواتف المحمولة على
الرغم من أنه كان لدينا أشخاص من جميع أنحاء العالم
يسجلون أجزائهم وينضمون
إلينا في بروفات جوقة افتراضية إذا كانوا
يريدون الركض على الأجزاء معنا ،
لذلك كان لدينا أشخاص من جميع أنحاء العالم
يتواصلون معًا في هذه التدريبات
وبعد ذلك يقومون بتسجيل
أجزائهم على هواتفهم
وإرسالها وسنقوم بتجميع المزيد معًا
ثم إنشاء الأغنية التي تسمعها الآن
[موسيقى]